we're hoping that we can help some
people that might be watching this who
are stuck in getting a project made find
a roadmap to maybe get unstuck I realize
in current times things are kind of in
limbo but any suggestions well I'd say
I'd say
one of the things you want to do is is
uh keep working I said it before earlier
meaning keep the train moving down the
tracks and if you're if you're just
getting started and you feel stuck
you may have to do some kind of
compromises I've had to do a lot
you may not make the film exactly that
you want the guy may say you may have
walking around
with a budget of a half a million
dollars for two years and a guy comes
and tells you I can give you two hundred
thousand just do it
you have to keep you have to just you
have to keep making things and and and
take
the good parts of what you make
and move that forward make it better
make take the lessons take the
experience take the connections
take the pieces and put it in your reel
but don't
allow
your idea of how you saw things playing
out
stop you from making something that is
possible to make
just
film it now I'm not one of those
proponents of the people that say well
just go out and film anything with your
iPhone or anything I think it creates a
little bit of a glut in the in the
system and it makes it harder for for
the buyers and so forth to really
distinguish you know go through
you know before they're going through 20
films now they're going to two thousand
but
if you feel
that
that your something's
not working and you just you have to
reimagine it
lower budget
action scene different ending
go to a distributor and and figure out
what they want I'm looking for a shark
movie okay
go that direction
and figure out where you know I like the
script but it's the beginning and the
ending doesn't work for me
you have to
submit and submit to the laws of supply
and demand
until such time as you can
have more control over that
so just keep
doing stuff keep saying yes
even if it's going to be hard even if
it's risky
say yes so I'll do it if you got this
much I'll do it because you don't want
to I'd rather be struggling
trying to make a two hundred thousand
dollar movie work than sitting at the
coffee shop with with the 500 000 budget
you know trying to figure out
who wants to
you know if they who wants to do it if
somebody says yes to that do it so don't
don't get out of your own ideas and just
let the
let let the supply and demand inform
what you the laws of supply and demand
inform what you do and take the risk
have to take the risk this is not gonna
there will be laws in this business
You're Gonna Lose you're not going to
hit home runs every time it's not going
to happen and you know what you're going
to strike out sometimes but you gotta
keep swinging at it
and
yeah that's why that would be that would
be my advice and make sure that you
listen
don't get caught up in how you see it
even if they tell you I don't like this
ending I don't you need two more action
scenes in it you need to put this actor
in it and not your friend from acting
class
you have to listen to that stuff just
keep going would do whatever it takes
and any opportunity that's that comes
your way grab it and take the risk you
have to there's no other way
is that something that you did in the
beginning you waited thinking that you
could only make a certain film at this
budget and then
the rich Uncle friend of the friend
whatever presented itself and you said
okay yeah yeah at first I was like well
the budget needs to be this and you know
you first you do budgets and then you go
find the money for the budget now now
they tell you how much they have and you
reverse engineer that that's just the
way it works and then you just you know
in and you you and it usually it's to
the penny you know
It's never enough so so you
um
you can get caught up in okay well I did
a budget and the budget's you know 3
million
well that movie's not worth 3 million
and if somebody tells you that you have
to listen to them
they say that word movies worth 850
000 I'll give you
um you know whatever you need paperwork
or whatever to get that you can do it
other than that
let me know
do it
just figure it out
go somewhere and do it figure out a way
to get it done
but
the last thing you want to do is
I can't remember who told me but as if
if you're not in making movies you're
not in the movie business you got to be
making movies
so just keep going just make the movies
do what it takes
and and take the risks
how did you get the names attached for
your first film
uh that's the line and they really like
the script Andy um that Andy Garcia
liked it or casting director showed it
to him it's really um
a really interesting role has a nice
twist to it
um we probably offered a little bit more
than we should but you're gonna have to
do that at first
until a director knows you director is
like a party it's like
um people
if if you're if you're a popular
director everybody wants to come to your
party so your Clint Eastwood
or or David Fincher you don't have to
beg an actor to they'll say I'll have
this guy to start this out if you're
unknown
you know they're going to be like well
who's this guy you know how good is the
story you know so so what where you want
to get to director wise is to where
people know you a little bit and say oh
okay Fraser's doing a film okay I mean I
have a version of that in the smaller
actors but you want to get the the
actors that have bigger cloth that can
get you the bigger budgets and then you
bring your other actors that you've
developed on the smaller films along
with you
someone he talks yeah money it's if you
don't it's it's money in the script you
know um you know the
key to any green light is the actor in
2022. so
um the actor signs on if if Brad Pitt
and and Tom Cruise sign out of your
movie people will throw money at you
it's there what's the hard thing to get
and they know it
so so you want them to
you know get to know you and you know
and it becomes easier once you work with
them a couple times or once you work
with them once and they trust you it
just becomes a phone call
do you go to the distributor first or
the investor first
uh to the distributor first okay yes and
they know these just they know the
investors because the investor wants to
see investor if it's traditional finance
and not like I said the rich Uncle if if
it's a traditional investor they want to
know they'll want to you have to present
your collateral the collateral was given
to you by the distributor so who you
really go to First is the actor
you attach the actor first
or you can go to this distributor and
say
I'm going to place an offer to this
actor
can you know will you back it they say
okay you know just whatever that movie
will be worth this much okay that will
inform how much you could pay the actor
and still make your film
say then once they say yes
then you can take that paperwork or they
take the paperwork to their financier
and begin the cash flow of the film
so sounds easy but it's it's got a lot
of every like it's kind of chicken and
egg in certain areas you know but if you
the thing is if you know the actors that
if you and they know you and you have a
good reel then it becomes a lot easier
that's why you have to keep working and
keep your network strong and keep your
real strong
so that you can
you can keep working
and people get to know you and then they
and then you build a reputation of being
you know good to work with that you do
good work that you know that people have
good time with you you know things like
that and you know that you do what you
say you're going to do things like that
so the answer is absolutely go to the
distributor first and uh or the sales
agent and then or then go to the actor
and then go to the finance
but for a first-time filmmaker is that
something that's done a lot is Dell
approach a distributor when they have
really no track record
well a lot of times you're going to say
send the script and it'll get lost in a
pile
um
so you're really best to go then with a
package if you can
meaning package meeting with an actor
say if this actor
and here's a script of this actor can we
do it so and then and then so you know
um
questions how do you get the actor
without having a firm offer you know
it's like I said chicken and egg
happening here all the time so that's
why
um you know you just have to figure out
how to
be a good bet be safe for your and for
your
distributor your distributor and your
investor be a safe bet that means you're
just gonna have to keep going down and
down and down on on the cost so that
until it makes sense for them to there's
a trigger number
that have you and same with the actor
the actor
is a trigger number to say yes then the
distributor has a trigger number to say
yes and then your
you know so and then your budget has to
be that way so so in other words it's
not going to be fun the first couple
films but I mean it'll be fun but it's
going to be it's going to be rough you
have to put in your time and then the
next time it's a little bit easier you
can call that same actor again hey um I
got another thing going on and what's up
can we do it sure see then you don't
have to jump to the same Loop but you
that would have never happened if you
hadn't done that other movie The
sacrifices will need to be made
and I think it's important